ah so much work to do
right let's get this letter started
what is this what is this thing what why
is it doing this I just want to write my
letter what are these options
oh dang it
how do I get rid of what ah who invented
this stupid paper clip that'd be me
[Music]
foreign
my name is Kevin atteberry and I write
and illustrate books for children back
in the 90s I had a graphic design
company got to do a little bit of work
from Microsoft and I was asked to design
some characters for a project called
Microsoft Bob which may be one of their
biggest failures it was software for
people having their first computer
experience they like the idea of these
characters that could tell what you were
trying to do and offer their assistance
after the failure of Microsoft Bob they
ported the character technology over to
Microsoft Office we went through 260
character designs to get down to the 10
that shipped with the product coming up
with clippy was not as big of stretch as
as you might have think and while it's
obviously an office thing I loved the
Simplicity of a paper clip as a
character I love the flexibility all the
things I could do I loved the fact that
I was just using eyes because eyes can
be so expressive and you know it
simplifies my work too right I think I
designed about 20 or 22 characters I had
a stapler I had a stubby little pencil I
had a coffee mug I do a lot of sketches
just hundreds of sketches once I got to
where I liked it I would scan it in then
start working on it digitally on my
Macintosh
once we had all the character designed
they were handed over to social
psychologists at Stanford University in
California to help us start winnowing
out some of the characters the
professors would bring you know general
public in they'd ask things like is this
character trustworthy is the character
likable does he have a sense of humor
through that process they were able to
eliminate characters until they got down
to the final 10 characters obviously
they needed a default one and obviously
the most trustworthy endearing engaging
likable character happened to be clippy
there were people there that were not
happy that clippy kept making it through
every level on this team my character
had risen to the top
oh thanks
two and a half three years that I did
from Microsoft was a really great time
in my life and it just seemed like maybe
it was a good time to leave
and then I didn't think much about it
until I kept hearing that oh yeah
Windows has shipped with this this
character this Paperclip
the disdain for him was just incredible
everywhere you turn to me people just
hated that pay-per-click they wanted to
turn them off there's no way to turn
them off and his functionality was too
basic and annoying for most people I
would never never include clippy in my
in my portfolio because I was so
embarrassed of him one time I was at a
client's office she was pulling
something up on her computer to show me
what she was looking for and a pop
Flippy
and I looked at it I go oh I I created
that
she looked at me and she goes you did
and she was so excited honestly and
clippy has opened so many doors for me
over the years people that just are very
receptive to it and now you know nobody
hates clippy now he's on The Simpsons
and Family Guy and he shows up
everywhere I had no idea you know
obviously how big he was going to be I
mean holy cow I could I've seen in the
future and realized I would have
probably tried to get my contract
written differently he's a character
that everybody understands his motives
he's a guy that just just wants to help
and he's a little bit too helpful
sometimes and there's something fun and
vulnerable about that it doesn't matter
if you like them or hate them
as long as you know who he is I have
cachet
foreign
[Music]